well as the crisis at the border now
appears to worsen
virtually by the week according to cbp's
own data republicans are accusing vice
president kamal harris of going
m.i.a missing in action now
gut-wrenching new images are showing
child migrants in cages
at a border facility in donna texas the
photos come from texas democrat
congressman henry cuellar
this as the media still remains locked
out of these facilities
now president biden officially tapped
vice president harris to lead the u.s
response to the crisis last week so far
she has not announced plans to travel to
the border republican congressman brian
babin
is among those pushing for a visit
sooner rather than later take a listen
we have invited
vice president kamala harris uh to
attend some of
our uh itinerary and see for herself
we thought it would be uh you know a
good thing to do for her to come down
and see exactly what's going on down
there since in the past she has thought
that president trump's uh uh policies
were cruel and humane and and uh and
that they were putting children in cages
we have not heard yet but we're hoping
so
so carly last week at president biden's
first white house press corps briefing
he explained exactly why he has not
announced a trip to the border or
undertaken a trip to the border yet he
said it's because like most disaster
areas
that happen across the country a
presidential visit requires a
whole heck of a lot of planning on the
ground it distracts from
the emergency response he said his
government's basically in crisis now
trying to deal
with this surge um of people but in a
you know particular unaccompanied minors
does that explanation
scratch the itch no no it absolutely
does not or else you know we wouldn't
see any
presidents at any um areas of crisis and
that's what uh the president's job
is imagine being the president or the
vice president a crisis unfolds on your
watch what's the first thing you do
you get on an airplane and go to the
affected area
um so you know president biden said
during the inauguration that he was
going to be
the president for all people and i if
you ask the border patrol
or the folks living down along the
southern border they would say that
right now he is failing
at that job i spoke to a rancher in new
mexico this morning
and he said that while children and
family units are getting a lot of
attention
he is seeing groups of young male
migrants
walking past his house every single
night and border patrol
has told him to be careful on his own
property
um so president biden feels like i'm
sure he can't go down there because then
it would
uh cause a it would essentially mean
that he would be admitting
that this is a crisis that rises to the
level of a presidential uh visit
the one thing that he could do very
quickly to change all this is implement
reimplement remain in mexico but he is
probably not going to do that because
that would mean that president trump's
policies were right
and his were wrong so we learned this
yesterday that border patrol thinks that
this crisis
is going to last for seven months um and
that means that this is going to be
seven months of a lot of people
coming into the country it's very
expensive for the united states
and also seven months of people claiming
asylum
who don't legitimately have asylum
claims and that clogs the system
creates a backlog for people that
legitimately do belong here
for reasons that affect their own
personal safety leslie i want to bring
you in here right away because i'm
guessing
you don't see the situation the same way
that carly just laid out
um tell us how you see it well i
uh uh quite frankly i i wouldn't say
that i think uh you know americans
whether the democratic republican you
know realize we have a problem this has
been a problem for 17 years
we have both democrats and republicans
that say this has been something that's
been you know
kicked down the road i don't think and i
would hope that the vice president is
not mia missing in action but more so
working on uh what is going to be the
strategy and then the policy dear
dealing with the northern triangle
nations in central america
uh dealing with mexico and dealing with
the root cause because until we deal
with the root cause
we haven't been able to you know for 17
years
stem the tide of these individuals
coming and i think one of the reasons
border patrol can say
hey this is probably going to happen for
the next seven months is because they
know what it's like historically
uh when the weather uh warms up and and
when we don't have winter
and also now that coveted numbers are
reducing in you know countries uh
throughout the world
uh so the bottom line is i do think that
the vice president should go to the
border
it could be some logistical problems
like the president had alluded to with
him not going to the border
and i certainly think that she should
come out and tell us
but i think more so it's better if she
tells us okay
i have met with the leaders of these
nations this is what we've concluded
and this is what we plan to do going
forward now leo somebody who
wants to go to the border and says that
they're probably going to go sometime
soon as former president trump he told
that to judge pirro on our
air on saturday night now my question
leo is
because we all know that former
presidents are not really supposed to
interfere with current presidents
domestic and foreign policy
republicans love the idea that president
trump's going to go to the border they
welcome it so how does he do that
how does trump go to the border and
avoid giving the impression that he's
meddling
well first of all that playbook julian
no longer exists
because i'll tell you right now barack
obama broke that program
uh he violated that policy of staying
quiet during the trump administration
and i think it's important what donald
trump did at the border was provide
national security and you know i think
chris wallace asked president uh
jan saki the the other day about whether
or not
on rolling back the trump policies hurt
this country
and she could not give him any credit
our border was secure
and last week joe biden lied to the
american public when he said
that more people more illegal aliens are
returning back to their home country
that is an outright lie we have been
bombarded with illegal aliens
not only who have covet but more
importantly they're given hotel rooms
and accommodations unlike our national
guard troops
and our homeless population it is an
outright embarrassment
at the southern border